hey guys Pete here there hasn't been a
lot of news about Game of Thrones Season
seven since they haven't really started
filming yet but we did get an
interesting interview with Dan and Dave
this week this will be a Game of Thrones
Season 7 preview with everything we've
heard since Comic Con so it will contain
potential spoilers for everything that's
happened in the series up to this point
Game of Thrones show owners did an
interview with deadline where they
talked about some season 6 stuff and the
challenges involved with doing a show
like this at the end they gave us some
tidbits on what to expect for season 7
in relation to the major characters this
is what they said about each of the big
players in their own words Daenerys
Targaryen D&D danny has a boundless
confidence in herself and her mission in
this world her sense of destiny makes
her a compelling charismatic leader a
messianic figure for multitudes she has
arguably the cleverest advisor on the
planet and tyrion lanister she has three
dragons an army of unsullied and a great
Dothraki horde what could possibly go
wrong so not much new there except for
the what could possibly go wrong part as
I've been working on my Queen Cersei how
long may she reign series this is
exactly what I've been thinking Dany is
just stacked at the moment but no part
of me thinks she's gonna actually just
walk into Westeros and be handed the
throne so this is a confirmation that
even though Danny looks invincible she's
gonna have a lot of problems Cersei
Lannister D&E Cersei will do anything to
win in the past the only factor limiting
her ruthlessness was her love for her
children now that her children are gone
nothing restrains her as she herself
said love is weakness a loveless Cersei
is a fearsome thing again this is more
of a confirmation than a reveal we'll
talk more about Cersei in a minute
though Jon Snow DND John's honorable
nature has proven a disadvantage in some
regards a man who plays by the rules
will have a harder time defeating men
and women who don't but John's nature
also provides one of his great strengths
his ability to win others to his cause
men who respected his courage and
honesty elected and more Commander of
the Nights Watch the free folk who had
never before aligned themselves with
kneelers chose the fight for Jon Snow
because they believed in him the Lords
of the north named him king in the north
because they realized he was their last
best chance to survive the war
to come the question will be whether an
honorable man can overcome dishonorable
enemy as a Oh Wilson wrote within a
group selfish individuals always win but
in contests between groups groups of
altruist always be groups of selfish
individuals so Jon Snow better hope this
is a contest between groups the night
King D&D strength he can raise the dead
and have them do his bidding weakness
he'll never be as funny as the Ice King
when asked about the ball on the Horn of
Joramun they said very clearly the wall
isn't a physical structure that is
keeping the army of the Dead out if it
were and if the wildlings managed to
make it over at least in theory someone
like the knight King hasn't so much more
in the way of both power and troops who
will do literally anything he says we've
been laying out the likelihood that it's
going to be more difficult to get past
the wall than that but we wanted to put
that basic prospect out there we'll keep
it at that for now dan and Dave also
talked about the difference between the
night King and other villains like
Ramsay who you know met his ultimate end
in season six they say that the night
King is more a representation of death
rather than evil they say evil comes
when you have a choice between that and
good and you choose the wrong way the
night King doesn't have a choice he was
created in that way and that's what he
is in some ways he's just death coming
for everyone in the story and for all of
us there was a lot of discussion about
Cersei and how far she will go to
protect her power now that she's sitting
on the Iron Throne they told us what I
think most of us already knew Cersei is
set up to go full-on batshit they say if
she had been more focused on her family
and less focused on enjoying her revenge
on someone who had done her wrong then
Tom and suicide probably never would
have happened that's what so much of the
next season is going to be about finding
out what Circe's mindset is and who is
she Cersei has certainly done a lot of
horrible things in her life and she
could be a very cruel person but the one
thing that was redemptive about her was
she genuinely loved her children now
they're all gone and I think that that
is very interesting for us who is she
without her children the answer is
something you'll find out about next
season to me this sense that Cersei will
be around for the entire season but not
sure if that means her death will be in
the finale or during season eight either
way I don't see her making it to the end
of the series on this trajectory and I
think that the Maggie the frogs prophecy
will play a big role
on that in her end prior to this
interview we also had a video that hints
at conflict between John and Sansa in
season seven they also kind of teased
about this at Comic Con so there
probably is something to it let's watch
the clip and we'll talk about it in a
second
Thrones is really at the heart of it
about dysfunctional families there's
always been tension between them because
since they were little Santa has always
looked up to her mother and always just
taken on her mother's views of
everything you know her mother really
didn't like John because of all a fair
thing doesn't mean they don't love each
other but it's just you know typical
sibling tension we need to trust each
other we can't fight a war amongst
ourselves with so many enemies now
I think John is oblivious he hasn't
actually learned his lesson from trying
to pay attention to what she's feeling
he says he has but he's asking her to
trust him
he's not listening and watching and
observing power I think that could be a
real problem for him
no cares is busted that starts good runs
through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day John's the right man for the
job
we all want a leader who's gonna be
decent and honorable and I think it's
definitely entitled to be running
Winterfell although Sansa might have a
problem with her I fear her relationship
with John Snow I think is an indication
of what's going to come and I'm not sure
it's gonna be quick the clips a bit odd
since they don't usually foreshadow big
plot points like this but at the same
time it seemed pretty obvious that
everything wasn't going to go smoothly
in the north they don't mention
Littlefinger but he'll probably play a
big part in that as well with such a
short amount of time left in so few
episodes I don't think this whole thing
will get drawn out but all of this makes
me think that the major characters will
start out with a big hurdle to get over
in the beginning of season 7 probably
the most telling thing D&D gave us in
the interview about John is that ego
Wilson quote in a group selfish
individuals win but when groups go at it
the one that is working together for a
cause
always went out against a group of
selfish individuals this sets the tone
the lead-up to the end and it will be
interesting to see what gets in the way
of each character in their journey so
what does it all mean at this point we
can get a good idea of where Game of
Thrones Season seven will take us each
of the main storylines are leading to
the real war which will probably occur
in season eight season seven looks to be
the set up where each character gets put
in some tough spots that will all fall
by the wayside once the White Walkers
advance I'll be making my predictions
videos soon now that I have a little
more info and I think the major
character stories are laid out pretty
clearly at this point so if you have any
questions you want me to address in
those leave them in the comments below
the video if you're wondering how to
keep yourself occupied until season
seven comes out and you've never read
the books you should check out my top 10
reasons to do so video it's spoiler free
so it doesn't ruin anything about the
show
or the books let me know which story you
think will dominate season seven and
which character you're most excited
about we didn't get any mention of Arya
and bran so what do you think season
seven has in store for them we get a
tiny thing about Jamie and his conflict
with what Circe's done but it doesn't go
into too much detail and I'll get into
that in a different video please like
this video and subscribe to my channel
for more game of Thrones related videos
I have a bunch of different scripts in
progress different series I'm working on
so there'll be a ton of new videos
before next season thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon
the king he's named king in the north
and she kind of gets no credit for it
Jon doesn't acknowledge everything his
sister has done for him after all that
they've been through and it's not that
she's looking for praise or anything she
did it because she wants revenge and
also because she wants a home back Jon
be so naive so dance is just a little
bit agitating it as well
you